c'est à la fin de la semaine que sera
élu le hula successeur de joan ue à la
tête de médecins sans frontières
la pédiatre québécoise restera ensuite
en poste quelques mois le temps de
compléter la transition 23 ans au sein
de msf dont six à la présidence
international marqué par des crises et
des tragédies
johan ue veut maintenant prendre un peu
de repos à ne dit pas ce qu'elle fera
ensuite mais chose certaine elle va
continuer de s'indigner devant la
justice comme elle l'a toujours fait
pendant son mandat
après six ans comme présidente donc
international de msf vous avez vu
tellement de choses vous avez vécu
tellement de choses à quel point ça vous
a changé vous je crois que six ans la
présidence international sa marque
quelqu'un parce que les défis ont été je
vous dirais hors normes on a fait face à
des crises qui ont été quelque peu de
précédents sont parle de les bols en
2014 2015 où c'était la plus grosse
épidémie dans l'histoire moderne de
l'épidémie d'ebola et peu près ça l'
attaque attaque fort sur windows qui a
eu lieu le 3 octobre 2015 où tout d'un
coup on a vraiment l'impression d'en
penser une ligne rouge et
et la crise des migrants qui pour moi
est un peu
un déni de notre humanité commune le
contexte de l'humanitaire a beaucoup
changé pendant vos demandeurs le
contexte a changé sur différents aspects
mais nous notamment qu'est ce qu'on voit
un médecin sans frontières c'est c'est
vous dire elle a l'air de l'action
humanitaire
autant de autant de la sécurité quand
tout est vu à travers le prisme de la
sécurité et donc on répond seulement aux
crises quand on se sent attaqué ou
cancon sans nos intérêts nationaux mis à
l'épreuve
donc c'est comme ça qu'on a vu qu'elle
est beau l'on ne se ment répondu six
mois plus tard le début de l'épidémie
parce qu'on dit oh mon dieu ça pourrait
arriver chez nous c'était la même chose
aussi parlera par la taxe sur les
hôpitaux c'est qu'on voit l'ennemi de
partout même dans les hôpitaux et donc
on sur des accords qui sont pas très
clair qu'un passage un patient avec un
combattant qui est blessé est impatient
on oublié ça tout d'un coup et avec les
migrants c'est que on a peur on ne parle
de l'étranger et donc tout d'un coup
quand quelqu'un traversent une frontière
y perd ses droits d'homme donc le
respect la dignité la protection vous
dit en fait qui a eu donc trois moments
marquants dans votre sous votre mandat
prenons par exemple koundouz koundouz
donc c'est la taxe d'un hôpital de msf
en afghanistan
[Musique]
pourquoi humainement ça vous a tellement
touché ce centre là est un centre où on
faisait la traumatologie et tourne cv
que comme on a une fracture l'endroit où
alips à faire guérir c'était le centre
mc12 et la nuit du 3 octobre 2015 et une
attaque qui étaient pressés sur le
bâtiment principal
cinq frappes quarante deux personnes ont
perdu la vie 14,1 nos collègues
donc on avait eu des actes a dans le
passé mais s'était jamais à répétition
comme ça donc c'est sûr que ça ça marque
c'est sûr que ça choque les américains
ont dit que c'était une erreur une
erreur à trois niveaux personnel
technique au niveau des standards
opérationnels
donc moi je passe une heure précise les
big bang welcoming de présence d'acteurs
joindre lieu ils te laissent
représentant b25 sans frontières
en tout cas 12 afghanistan and following
d'ios attaque en art roman center
one of the survivors and ms hafner ton
message tu es tu à kitz centimes et
délits msf staff weston thalys trauma
center was his own over again
oui ça date et tommy billydjo fait des
dieux no they did you know there will be
blood pour les afghans ça a été terrible
parce que les gens étaient réfugiés dans
cet hôpital à vous leur aviez dit
d'aller se réfugier dans cet hôpital que
c'était un endroit sécuritaire
oui je pense que au delà de la tacc on a
eu aussi un sens de culpabilité par
rapport à cet événement là parce que oui
la ligne de front bouger à ce moment là
et les gens nous demandaient où est-ce
qu'on peut être en sécurité
on avait 12 personnels bennoo on pense
que le talent pur est un endroit
sécuritaire et c'est vrai quelques
quelques zones de personnes avaient
amené leurs familles
dans ce soit de l'hôpital donc certes
oui ça nous est extrêmement extrêmement
choquée
[Musique]
la crise des migrants évidemment ça avec
tout ça a duré de nombreux mois on a vu
toute sorte d'image on en parle moins
aujourd'hui vous vous disais il ya une
ligne rouge qui a été qui a été franchie
à ce niveau là qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire par là on ne rien régler la seule
chose c'est qu'on ait dévier le flux
migratoire donc moins de personnes qui
traversent par exemple la mer
méditerranée et moins de gens qui
arrivent sur les plages européennes
mais ça veut dire qu'elles sont bloquées
ailleurs parce que quand on a vu ces
images en libye d'esclaves
aujourd'hui quand on était en 2018 2017
c'est quand même ça c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement choquant quand même qu'on
a vu là moi je considère que c'est une
des choses les plus les plus troublantes
indécente que j'ai vu de ma vie parce
que on contribue à cette souffrance là
quelque part en empêchant les gens de
venir et de sortir de la libye
aujourd'hui c'est tellement une crise en
libye qu'on devrait évacuer tout le
monde des centres de détention
et donc pour moi je crois que ça demeure
une tâche morale dans notre histoire
quand les gens vont comprendre
l'histoire et l'ampleur de la souffrance
humaine moyens je me rappelle une maman
m'avait dit je croyais de d'avoir le
meilleur de l'europe
j'ai l'impression d'avoir eu le pire
parce qu on leur ferme les portes de
plus en plus vous êtes vous voyez la
montée du populisme un peu partout en
europe et aux états unis
même ici maintenant on commence à
vouloir resserrer un peu les règles
ça vous ça vous choque ça vous ça vous
fasse ça monsieur et je pense qu'il faut
regarder quand même
l'évolution de commandes vu les migrants
travers les temps dans les années dans
un et 60 70
quand les gens fuyaient les régimes
communistes étaient des héros après ça
ils sont venus ils sont à travers le
temps c'est devenu plus comme une
lourdeur jusqu'à certains points puis
aujourd'hui c'est carrément peinture et
l'immigrant comme comme des menaces donc
cette évolution l'eau vers le bas elle
est catastrophique et les tragiques et
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux gens qui
disent y regarde ces situations-là voit
ces images veulent peut-être aidé mais
se sentent impuissants devant toute
cette détresse qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez mais moi je pense qu'il faut
qu'ils en parlent
il faut qu'il le dise que ça fait pas
partie de leur valeur
parce que nous on a quand même le
bonheur d'être peu comme les migrants ou
les réfugiés on est le coup les
constituants les citoyens d'un
gouvernement et donc on peut dire le
gouvernement sachant très bien qu'on est
en en campagne électorale
quelles sont nos valeurs et ce qu'est ce
qu'on s'attend d'un gouvernement
donc je pense qu'avoir je vous irez un
comportement de citoyen engagé et
responsable est clair on devrait dire si
on y boit bien avec ça que nous on
demeure toujours une terre d'accueil au
canada il n'en tient qu'à nous de garder
notre part d'humanité identique et nous
de voir l'humanité dans l'autre même
dans dance et du migrants qui fuient
même dans le patient d'ebola ou de la
rougeole il n'en tient qu'à nous et
j'espère que collectivement on va faire
ce choix là on faire le choix de notre
communauté comme tata humanité commune
j'espère que ça va être
[Musique]